This video is brought to you by Wix,
a wise crack.
Jared here,
Jack is back.
That means it's time to saddle up and
head back to the strange and depressing
world of Hollywood.
Now we've already talked about Frodo
narrative and distraction in previous
videos,
but this season really dives deep into
an idea that's always been present in
the show,
that idea loneliness,
who's comfortable with it,
who's uncomfortable with it,
and who takes 100 painkillers a day to
avoid it at all costs through its
ensemble of dysfunctional relationships.
Bojack gives us a fresh and quite
nuanced perspective on loneliness,
not often seen on TV.
Can loneliness be healthy or even
necessary?
Well,
let's find out in this wisecrack quick
take on bojack horseman season five and
of course spoilers ahead,
but real quick,
a shadow tour,
new channels sponsor wicks.
We're building a new website using wix
that we'll have a bunch of fun and
interactive features,
including a way for you to vote on what
we should cover in an upcoming episode.
So more on that at the end of the video,
but for now,
back to bojack.
So first guys,
a quick recap.
This season revolves around the
production of bojack's new TV show,
Filbert,
where bojack navigates a semi
relationship with his Costar,
Gina.
Meanwhile,
Princess Carolyn attempts to adopt a
baby.
Todd manages his career as a VP at what
time is it right now,
dot com and Mr.
peanut butter and Diane finalized their
divorce in an attempt to move on with
their lives as early as the first line.
Willingness is established as a central
theme of the season.
Nothing lonelier than a party.
Good thing.
I don't need anyone or I might feel
lonesome and as we'll see,
every major character struggles with
this in their own way.
Let's start with the most obvious one.
Diane,
who is struggling to reconcile her
identity as a newly divorced single
woman.
We've seen in previous seasons how hard
she used to try to keep up with Mr.
peanut butter's expectation speed.
A fun party goer like him having to find
herself in relation to him for so long,
only made her focus on her supposedly
shortcomings as an introvert while
abandoning other aspects of herself that
she actually liked.
This is all the stuff that cool,
20 something Diane had to put away when
she moved in with old man peanut butter.
In episode two,
we follow her non sequentially across a
timeline that starts with her hitting on
bojack.
You could totally make out right now
during a moment of lonely desperation.
Then after finding out that Mr peanut
butter has a new girlfriend,
she flees to Vietnam for a solo trip.
Once there she's rendered doubly alone
by her inability to speak Vietnamese and
her fellow Americans assumptions that
she doesn't speak English.
You Viet Nam.
No me,
America.
She copes with her loneliness in various
ways.
At one point,
engaging in a mega brief romance with a
grip,
but every interaction puts Diane Moore
Ilities from a conversation with todd
about something.
I'm supposed to go to the roller rink
later.
Hopefully there won't be any mob bosses
there.
What am I saying?
That's so random to the grips.
Endless pontification.
Diane realizes often interacting with
the outside world only leaves her
feeling more alone.
She eventually comes to terms with her
romantic aloneness,
apologizing to bojack for her mixed
messages and admitting that I just
really need a friend right now over the
course of the season,
she seems increasingly self actualized
from being able to comfort her romantic
semi rival pickles to performing a solo
intervention for bojack.
Now more on that later,
generally she's able to exist more
truthfully now that she's not dating
someone who doesn't align with our
values.
Even her therapist admits that
sounds like our time together is done.
What fact that you're setting a boundary
is good.
Go forth with the tools that I've given
you
through Diane.
We see that self sufficiency and
embracing solitude can be key to
realizing the truest,
strongest version of yourself.
Now,
while Diane is able to be happily alone,
other characters attempt to make
relationships work in order to avoid
confronting loneliness.
Just as Diane's relationship with Mr.
peanut butter makes her obsess over her
fun quotient.
Todd's relationship seemed to only bring
out his two shortcomings.
First,
in his relationship with Yolanda,
todd is hurt by the hyperfocused on his
lack of life direction.
Why did you tell her
family?
I went to college.
Um,
I dunno.
I guess I just wanted you to seem
impressive.
Ultimately he decides to end the
relationship.
Yolanda,
we need to break up.
Second.
He's so eager to make things work with
emily that he constructs a sex robot,
which he is convinced could compensate
for his disinterest in sex.
While emily isn't super into boning the
sex robot,
the big wigs at what time is it right
now.
Dot Com are impressed by its Moxie and
the robot is ultimately promoted to CEO.
Todd ultimately destroys the sexual
robot and takes off his executive suit,
thereby eliminating the parts of himself
that we're trying to please Yolanda and
emily.
As with Diane Todd's interactions.
Show how some romantic relationships can
leave you feeling more alone and more.
And now for Princess Carolyn in episode
five,
we get some deeper insights into her
past learning how she went from being
the helps knocked up daughter at the
mercy of her boyfriend's answering
machine tape dynasty only to miscarry
and find herself on her own instead of
mourning the life she lost.
She created an entirely new one for
herself by moving to La and clawing her
way up the Hollywood ladder.
It's worth noting that her latest
journey and selfsufficiency also came
after a miscarriage,
the one that blew up her relationship
with Milton.
Once again,
we see Princess Carolyn land on her feet
and channel the same bravery as her
teenage self and starting over after a
difficult loss while sitting in the
hospital waiting to meet her maybe baby.
She admits to Milton that fourth season,
Princess Carolyn did want him to stick
around the night.
She kicked him out.
I wish you'd stayed with me that night.
Do you told me to leave?
I guess the lesson is don't listen to
me.
Right.
However,
later she clearly tells him to leave
saying that she doesn't want to raise
the baby with him,
and this time she means it.
She's what?
She wants.
Self sufficiency.
For instance,
Carolyn's joke about her baby's name,
untitled Princess Carolyn project,
so just that as with her previous career
successes,
Princess Carolyn will manage single
motherhood just fine.
All right,
so Diane Todd and Princess Carolyn's
journeys through season five illustrate
various takes on that double edge sword
of loneliness and self sufficiency,
which brings us to Mr.
peanut butter,
Mr.
peanut butter also fits this narrative
because as the character most in need of
company,
he's also the least inclined to self
reflections.
No,
I'm not tough enough.
I'll show them how tough I can be.
We'll be back with more of the red
carpet pre show fashion stravaganza.
Unlike the other characters,
Mr.
peanut butter rarely appears to want
anything beyond fame,
fun and parties.
He seems physically incapable of being
alone,
getting with the first half his age dog
lady he meets after signing his divorce
papers as a serial monogamist.
He made desperately hide from loneliness
or self reflection,
seeking solace in relationships the same
way he seek solace in loud parties.
In the Halloween episode,
Mr.
peanut butter gets dangerously close to
introspection as he wonders how each of
his wives became bitter and unhappy by
the end of their relationship.
What's the common denominator?
Diane offers some insights.
You keep dating women in their twenties.
I do do that are not fully formed yet.
Life changes.
People know about me.
The women he marries eventually grow up
while Mr.
peanut butter remains the same.
It seems that in constantly dating women
who are younger than him,
Mr.
peanut butter has carved out a
convenient emotional niche he can
continue to occupy as he replaces each
consecutive life with a younger,
more fun version.
This safe paint by numbers approach to
marriage has kept Mr.
peanut butter happy but prevented him
from maturing in any meaningful way.
Ultimately,
Mr peanut butter reveals himself to be
truly pathological in his need to be
coupled up when instead of telling
pickles the truth about his infidelity
and risking losing her,
he decides to put a radio and finally
our boy bojack.
While Mr peanut butter may be needy,
at least he's totally upfront about
bojack.
On the other hand,
it has a more complex and more painful
relationship to the outside world from
Holly Holly Hawk in the middle of the
night to inform her that he liked her on
instagram.
Let you know that I started your
instagram photo
to pretending to match Gina's blahzay.
Take on the relationship.
We work together,
we make six together.
We don't talk about her feelings and yet
sometimes I've been grudging respect can
blossom into blossoms,
into nothing is when I was going to say
you go bojack's need for human slash
animal.
Companionship is palpable.
Pojoaque has gone the Mr.
peanut butter route in the past,
getting with women to avoid solitude,
a a toxic pattern that peaked with the
nears seduction of his ex girlfriends,
teenage daughter.
This season piece kind of dating these
supremely Jaden,
Gina,
who doesn't appear to need anything from
him emotionally.
I love
being alone.
I wish were alone right now,
leaving him
just as lonely as before so he decides
to bypass the whole learning to be alone
with your thoughts thing by altering his
state of being,
enter painkillers writer Johann Hari
makes a compelling case for considering
drug addiction.
As a disease of bonding.
Humans have an innate primal need to
bond and when they're unable to bond
with other people,
they'll bond with a negative behavior
like smoking or gambling.
Essentially,
he argues that substance use is a
substitute for meaningful human
connection,
and while researchers are also studying
how other social and economic factors
can influence addiction in the fictional
world of bojack,
loneliness seems like a closely,
Oh,
Jack Find Solace and drugs even as the
embed him deeper into a fantasy world,
increasingly cutting him off from the
people around him.
He begins to see friends and loved ones
as tools for getting what he wants.
Gina is a tool for helping him sees the
limelight,
and Hollyhock is a tool for helping him
steal his pills back from Gina's
medicine cabinet.
Our sense of Bojack's loneliness is
augmented by the Filbert TV show.
Narrative.
Gilbert is a hard boiled loaner
detective with a penchant for secrets
and grizzly voiceover.
Why do you still use a landline?
What am I supposed to tell her?
I'm just an old fashioned guy,
or maybe I like things that are plugged
to the wall.
Something to grab onto.
If I start floating away from the
opening lines of the series,
bojack tries to imply that he relates to
the character as a fellow loaner slash
Sinek.
This develops into an ongoing joke about
the similarities between the two.
The set of the show looks exactly like
bojack's house and boat,
constantly wearing his silver costume
offset.
It's a costume I.
I just finished filming a show.
Normally people return the costume.
Also bojack frequently reach too deeply
into his characters narrative despite
reminders that it's not about you,
you know,
Filbert.
By the end,
he's become so dissociated,
he's completely lost himself in the
character,
even the character filbert loses track
of where he begins and ends inventing a
make believe partner who he blamed for
his wife's murder.
Rather than taking responsibility for
it,
there's no record of you ever having a
partner at all.
You say you killed your wife and the
chief and the coroner and the others.
Similarly,
bojack loses any distinction between
himself and Filbert also because he
can't cope with the horrible things he's
done.
The result of this disassociation bojack
pretty much retreats into a fantasy
world where he does crazy like choke.
Gina.
At one point,
he comes face to face with the bloated
balloon version of himself as if to
illustrate the fact that his inability
to face himself is ultimately to blame
for all of his problems.
In an interesting moment in the season
finale,
bojack begs diane to write one of her
Internet takedowns of him.
He wants everyone to know about his
worst behavior.
He wants to be despised,
chastise,
and punished.
Here bojack craves the feeling of being
held accountable by the world for the
same exact reason he craves it's company
praise and romantic attention because he
has no consistent sense of self.
He needs the world to reconcile his
persona as lovable Hollywood,
leading man and narcissistic creep
because he can't seem to do it on his
own.
A soap actualized,
Diane is no longer interested in playing
bojack's games and diagnosis is request
for what it is self serving.
Eventually,
Diane convinces him,
but the only person whose job it is to
hold him accountable.
He is himself.
I am asking to be held accountable
and I'm telling you,
it's not going to happen.
Whatever you put in that story,
no one is going to hold you accountable.
You need to take responsibility for
yourself
and faster than UPC.
Narcotics anonymous.
She's persuaded him to go to Rehab,
so what are we to take from bojack
season five?
It cannot rely on other people.
Bojack,
well,
not quite.
Oh,
Jack and his dad's certainly know how to
put a pessimistic spin,
our relationships,
but we shouldn't buy into their bleakest
insights.
While we can't hide ourselves in the
company of others,
we have options beyond live and die
alone.
While romantic relationships may fail or
prove toxic,
it's the platonic friendships that
radiate through season five,
whether it's the budding roommate hood
between todd and Princess Carolyn,
or the lasting bond between Diane and
bojack.
They may have their ups and downs and
stolen cheese sticks,
but they prove uniquely enduring.
Bojack starts the season claiming he
doesn't need anyone,
but he ends up knowing there's one
person who you can count on his friend
Diane.
So what do you guys think?
Are we all alone in the world?
Our romantic relationships elaborate
traps for making us feel bad about
ourselves and is there power in being
able to tolerate loneliness.
Let us know what you think the comments
and as always,
thanks for watching,
but before you go,
we have an announcement.
In the coming months,
we're going to be launching some
exciting new community features on a
brand new website created with our new
channels sponsor wix.
Wix is a great platform to create
websites for any new project,
business,
event,
blog,
or pretty much any endeavor you can
think of.
We've been planning out our new site and
had been blown away by all the options.
There's the wicks pro gallery,
which is an amazing multimedia gallery
where you can post an enhancer images,
wicks events where you can set up
everything you need to put on a show or
a party and the comments APP which you
could include on your site to interact
directly with your audience.
It's all very professional,
high quality,
and you have total creative freedom to
use their tools and create your own
personal,
unique and original masterpiece.
So whether you've never launched a
website or you're a seasoned pro,
the encourage you to try out wicks and
see what a great experience it is and
stay tuned because we have some exciting
stuff rolling out for you on our wix
website that will help us connect
further with you guys.
So thanks for watching.
And as always,
guys,
piece.